okay well so we've already got a long
list of of of ways of of fitting
non-linear functions
there's another
whole family of of methods called local
regression
in fact
rob wasn't there a phd thesis from
stanford on
local regression i don't remember
rob's phd pieces was called local
likelihood and was an extension of these
local regression ideas to a whole range
of problems
and it's still used widely today i
wouldn't say widely
you're you're too modest
so
here we have
we're not going to go in great detail
into local regression but i'll just give
you the idea
here we have a some data
and
we've got a region over here
where we put a linear function just to
the data in this region
the points in the region are the orange
points right so it's a local set of
points and so we locally for the linear
function
and in fact we fit it by weighted least
squares and the weights are given by the
heights of
this kernel here right so the highest
weights are given to points at the
target point which is where this orange
dot is then the weights die down as we
move away
okay
and from doing all that whole linear
function you'll just get one fitted
value at this point over here
but then the idea is that you slide the
target point along and as you slide it
along the whole region slides along so
here we see
the target point at this point over here
there's the waiting function
the orange points have moved right
so we fit in locally at this region over
here
we fit a linear function and the fitted
value is taken to be this orange point
here
at the target point
and so as we slide the region along or
the target point along this whole system
slides along and we fit different linear
functions
and that traces out the orange curve
over here
and the reason we like to fit locally
linear as you might think why don't we
just fit a local constant or like a
moving average
is that it does much better for example
at the boundaries
it it it gives you a much better
extrapolation at the boundaries
so this is called local regression and
it's a very popular way of of
of fitting non-linear functions but just
focusing locally on the data
turns out yeah so it's probably fair to
say that
lowest and cubic splines or cubic
smoothing spines are probably the two
best ways of doing smoothing and if you
set the degrees of freedom about to be
equal roughly they look pretty similar
too in general would you agree that's
right so either one of these is a good
choice
so as rob it says lowest is the function
in r for fitting is this local
regression and we'll we'll play with
that a little bit in the lab and you'll
see it's it's very easy to use
so we're not going to say anything much
more about local regression but the
concept of local regression is important
you can read more about it in the book
and in our in our other book elements of
statistical learning and you'll see it's
actually a very rich area and and allows
you to do lots of flexible things
okay
the final topic generalized additive
models
so the general idea is that you're going
to fit non-linear functions in a bunch
of variables at the same time but the
additive in the name means that you're
going to retain the additivity of linear
models the reason that's attractive is
because it leads to interpretable models
so here our model for y is a additive
function of the different x's
right so we've got a function of x1 a
function of x2 and a function of xp
these are different variables in the
model
and once you fit this model
you can plot the different contributions
to the to the fitted model
so if if
if the first variable is here
we've got a non-linear function of year
and then we've got a non-linear function
of age
and the third variable in this case
there were three variables was education
and that was a factor variable and so
their piecewise constant function is a
natural thing to fit one constant for
each of the levels
but the point is the additive model
gives you a picture that you can
look at and appreciate the contributions
of each of the functions each of the
variables to the composite model
okay
and
and so the technology is about
fitting
nonlinear functions of of several
variables in this additive form
so
you can fit a generalized additive model
very easily using some of the earlier
tools for example natural splines
so it's as simple as this let's suppose
we want to fit an additive model in year
and age we can just have a call to
linear model lm
right and we give it
two terms we've got the response wage we
have a natural spline in here with five
degrees of freedom plus a natural spline
in age with five degrees of freedom
oh sorry plus education so that's the
previous term unit education is already
a factor variable so it will
automatically fit the piecewise constant
function
okay
and that will do it for you
as we said earlier the coefficients that
you end up because this term natural
spline in year degrees of freedom equals
5 will actually generate a basis matrix
for doing natural cubic splines
so that's a matrix of of x's
contributions to the model matrix and
each one of them is going to get a
coefficient
but we're not interested in the separate
coefficients we're interested in the
overall function that it fits so it's a
fitted function or this this part of it
that for each part of it that's
interesting
so this previous plot here was produced
by plot.gam
if you if you try to
plot this model which is fit by lm by
just using the the generic function plot
it'll make a plot that for linear models
which which not going to give you the
right plot but if you use plot.gam it'll
treat it as an additive model and plot a
plot that looks very much like the one
in the previous slide
focusing on the functions rather than
the co
the residuals and whatever
the linear model plot does
so of course with with generalized
additive models you can you can mix
terms so you can have some terms linear
some non-linear
and you can use for example the anova
function to compare models and test
whether term should be linear or
non-linear
you can also use
other
methods for smoothing so for example yes
here we use gam to fit the model because
in the first variable we want a
smoothing spline in here so there we use
the symbol s to tell gam that it wants
to use a smoothing spline with five
degrees of freedom
and just to be
interesting the second term we want to
fit with low s so there the shortcut is
lo
in age and there we specify the width of
the of the window the local window by
something called a span which is the
fraction of the data in the window
and then plus education
so
that's that's like a fully blown
generalized additive model
gams are additive which means there
aren't interactions in the model
now you can put lower directions in
by just including them in a natural way
and and there's several ways of doing
that you do get things called bivariate
smoothers that take several variables
two or more variables or you can put in
interactions in other forms for example
this is a way you can fit a bivariate
function in age and year using natural
splines
it's it creates a tensor product of the
of these two sets of bases and and
results in a bivariate function
so this is somewhat more detailed but
you can do this and again you can look
at
look i don't think you'll see details in
in the current book but in elements of
statistical learning you can certainly
see about doing things like this
you can fit gam models for
classification it's the same idea here
we fit in the logit of the the
probability as an additive model
and
in this case when you do a plot it will
plot the contributions to the logit
right because
the fitted probabilities are not
additive in the functions but the logit
is additive
and so there we get the
logit this was actually fit using the
following gam expression to call to gam
so there's our binary response
we asked for a linear term in here
a smooth term in eight foot by smoothing
spline with five degrees of freedom
and then the education term
and we tell gam the family is binomial
so that's just like glm we
tell the family was binomial and it
knows to fit the logistic regression
model
interesting to see the standard error
bands for the linear function
it's giving you a standard errors for
the slope you're not there's no
intercept in these terms they're all
centered at zero so the slope is of
interest here and of course a standard
error for a slope is going to be like a
cone-shaped bowtie kind of standard
error band
so that's a generalized additive model
okay
well so that's it that's a that's a
whole
collection of tools you have for fitting
non-linear functions
some of them you can fit directly using
lm and glm and for the more
sophisticated ones you use the g the gam
package in r
there's also a package called mgcv which
is an another package that has gam
models in it
also using smoothing splines slightly
different approach
to to what we take but
you can use those as well
so you have plenty tools at your
disposal
in our next section i think we're going
to talk about tree based methods which
are
non-linearities as well but involving
more than one variable the interaction
between variables so it's a good way of
finding non-linearities but of variables
in combination
so we'll talk about things like cart and
other other tree-based methods for
non-linearities